well i think the question is how do
people feel it's good to see positive
figures but how do people actually feel
and the fact is uh the truth of the
matter is that people are earning 1 600
pounds on average less now than they
were in 2010 almost half of the people
in our country living in poverty are
actually
in work and then if you look at the
nature of the work that people are doing
uh you saw from anushka's package there
what ed ball said we've got 1.8 million
zero hours contracts we've got
increasing numbers of part-time people
who are wanting to work full-time at the
moment we've got major productivity
issues that paul johnson just referred
to in that report we've got the lowest
rate of productivity apart from japan
and g7 so our our people are working the
longest hours amongst the longest hours
in western europe
but are not producing as much in the
same amount well let's unpack that a bit
because i understand what you're saying
nonetheless if you
apply the straightforward sort of ronald
reagan are you better off than you were
at the time of the last election
actually what today's figures show is
that household incomes are up that
growth uh is up uh and i've accepted
yes but the question is how do people
feel i've been at streams bingo today
this afternoon talking to some of
the residents there and one lady there
just stopped me and told me about her
utility but she's got whopping great
utility bill and she said to me i don't
know what i'm going to do about this so
i'm not look i'm not going to dispute
that the figures uh suggest you know a a
a slightly better picture
but how do people feel and if you look
at other figures on productivity as paul
johnson just cited on exports the
coalition government promised it was
going to double exports to a trillion
pounds and get more than a thousand
extra businesses
by 2020
they're not heading out we'll go up to 3
million in fact i'm not sure i'm not
sure that's right i don't know i don't
think i don't think i don't think that
we did say that but also let's not
forget the pain that people be through
this is the slowest recovery in a
hundred years the fact that people have
had five years of pain and hardship i
mean george osborne he can go and write
his pieces in the sun newspapers saying
it's all good but that isn't that's just
not the reality i mean how out of touch
are these people that is not the reality
for so many people in our country and
we've got to change that no but most
people know that times have been very
hard and in fact the peak was two years
back into the last labour government
around about 2008 i think i think what
people want have been dropping since
then but what people want if we're
talking about economic stewardship which
is i suppose what people are talking
about elections the conservatives as you
know are saying that they have put the
economy back on track in the right way
and they are saying
albeited it slowly that people are now
feeling the benefits of that well i
think we're lucky because we've got a
very rich diverse dynamic business
community and thankfully because of
their efforts our economy is in a better
place right now than it has been in the
past but the question is i think what
your viewers want to know from me i
suppose is i can tell you how they've
been getting repeatedly wrong but how do
we want to get things right exactly they
don't know what yeah and we want to get
we want to we want to get wages up
because we know the reason that they've
missed their debt and deficit reduction
targets is wages have been stagnating so
we're going to get the minimum wage to
eight pounds and that's parliament we're
going to incentivize employers to pay a
living wage through tax rebates if we're
going to attack productivity and get it
up we need to ensure people are getting
the technical and vocational skills that
we don't have enough of in our economy
and that means more and better quality
apprenticeships we need to get rates of
business investment outlook and we've
got to remain a member of the eu if we
want to do something about our exports i
want to come to the eu and we know where
the victorians currently are taking us
yeah but we also yeah
we also know where public opinion is on
the eu and if say in the eu is such a
no-brainer a lot of people would say
well why not just clear this up and say
we'll have a referendum as well because
i don't believe that is the priority of
the british people and certainly having
a referendum at the arbitrary date of
2017 with all the uncertainty that will
create i mean just take the uncertain
earlier referendum take the uncertainty
that was created by the scottish
referendum and multiply that at least
tenfold to give you a sense of the
uncertainty that a european referendum
would cause i people you know i've been
in swindon today we were launching our
offer to small businesses yeah cutting
business rates giving them
when a lower than swindon announced new
employment new unemployment plans yes
and also so you talk about a card yeah
also so let's see what they're worried
if britain uh withdraw from the european
union but the fact is that question mark
is hanging over the nation the
conservatives say they're going to let
the people decide why won't labor it
claims to be the people's party why
would you let the people decide this is
not the priority of the british people
but nobody's talking we're not asking
them no one has talked to me today about
the need for a referendum the questions
that ed balls and i were taking earlier
sophie bridge was there asked i asked
sophie they're asking about the nature
of their work but you're asking about
apprenticeships
you're not going out to people you you
said that was a bit that was
some labour members in there but they
were business there were businesses
people think there should be a
referendum on europe
i think people's fundamental priorities
are for us to save our nhs from the
crisis that we see
i'm sorry if you look at different
surveys of people and you talk to people
on the doorstep yeah they will talk to
you about the nhs they will talk to you
about um explosives
they will talk to you about what's going
on in terms of class sizes in our school
people are not saying to me and saying
number my number one priority is
an arbitrary date of 2017. and they've
got all these issues they want us to
focus is anybody other than someone
who's already going to vote labour is
campaigning seriously saying that the
tories are setting out to destroy the
nhs or to destroy the state school
system or to destroy the university
system they're not saying that to you
either adam the question is what has
happened under their watch and what
we've seen happen under the watch you
want to talk about the nhs we've seen
more than a million people waiting more
than four hours in a e yeah to get
treated we're seeing more people waiting
longer to get an appointment with their
do you also know well i'm actually just
telling you the reality is
reality of people's situation no i'm
saying there is a reality i think people
have a problem i'm just saying i'm just
wondering whether
picking statistics on these issues when
the fundamental underlying factor is of
the conservative government or labor
government or a liberal democrat
government would all want to maintain
those public services is really a
particularly constructive way of
pursuing an argument i think the
question is am i saying that uh the
conservative parties want to every
single member of the conservative party
every minister wants to abolish the nhs
i don't know they can speak for
themselves but what i do know is what i
see in the local hospitals that have
served the constituency i've had the
privilege of representing and the strain
that i've seen in a e there it's
perfectly fair i think for us to ask
people to judge us by record in the
constituency that i've represented
during our time in office we have six
new uh and improved healthcare centers
we had nine shore start children's
centers i honestly don't think over the
last five years you can point to
anything and i'll ask your viewers to
reflect on this they can make a judgment
they know what's going on down their
road think about what tangibly have you
seen this government deliver because i
look in my own area um in my part of
london and i actually honestly can't see
anything that they've delivered over the
last four or five
extra of years services you had in your
constituency well i'm talking about our
time in office that's why you introduce
whatever you see i'm talking about i'm
talking about those things but i'm
actually asking i think what it's a real
test i can literally point to sure start
children centers i can point to new
health centers i talk to old age
pensioners who've benefited from pension
credit i can talk to people who have
said child credit i can talk to people
who've seen class sizes reduced in our
secondary schools
and they say there is no doubt that the
over 60s are better off but the question
is what do people see in their street
how do they feel and like you said we
can quote statistics yeah but people
will go on the tangible things that they
see in their community and how they feel
and that's ultimately the test in these
things